franck buenos aires voici mosler la gare
d'eau à l'interview pinceau l'art
culture c'est aussi la peinture arthur à
ricardo master bonsoir bonsoir
après une évocation très jeune mais tu
as commencé par faire du théâtre
[Applaudissements]
je commençais redessinant signer avec un
crayon sous le bras mais comme tout le
monde mais après je continue un seul
manquait à partie des ventes en jeu
commençait à faire un peu plus mélangé
avec d'autres choses la danse la musique
et petit à petit je suis aussi utiliser
des performances dans les rues de buenos
aires ensuite est parti en europe à part
toi moi et les chants qu'ils ont fait
avec moi je sais pas s'il ya d'autres
pièces mais tu vas maintenant tout le
monde le signe aussi tu es parti en
europe barcelone amsterdam londres en 71
et tu vas monter un théâtre qui sapait
le théâtre en poudre alors c'est quoi ça
c'était une compagnie de théâtre
itinérante il y avait beaucoup de
musiciens des danseurs comédiens c'était
très pictural c'est pour ça que c'était
être proche de la peinture j'arrêtais
faire la facture pour faire la peinture
du théâtre et s'appelait quatre ampoules
à paris ça peut les parties est en
hollande
de la poudre stella la poudre de cette
fois ci passe quand même beaucoup de
feux d'artifice de la poudre maquillage
et cédez pas à la poudre et commentés
passer du théâtre à la peinture j'ai
fait c'est toujours la peinture c'est
vrai que pendant 13 70 et 90 ans j'ai
pas montrer parce que t'es trop occupé
avec les théâtres et j'ai dessiné tout
même les mêmes d
les pièces de théâtre j'avais un sourire
tout été dessiné par les costumes les
cordes et après oui après un moment je
fais un peu fatiguée de porter tout ça
c'était pas une compagnie subventionnait
ni installer bon moment je craque un peu
quand ça commence à marcher chars
étaient bonnes j'ai commencé petit à
petit à faire des expos a publié donc
voilà j'ai finalement je suis un peu
débordé par la peinture donc parfois
j'ai envie de retourner en 85 ans tu
l'explosion de la figuration libre est
devenu c'est devenu star la nom de nom
et star compagnie malabar a explosé en
même temps que la figuration les masser
par la figuration libre s'est plu
nouvelle que moi ils sont une dizaine
d'années puisque de moins que moi et
donc bon mais il y en a pas je suis un
peu pionniers si on veut mais
bon bah il a les jambes après qu'il y
ait en france il porte son nom partout
mais sont des garçons très sympa oui
c'est l'autre côté c'est vrai c'est dur
de l'étiquette parce que tu es il ya une
expression sur toi et extraordinaire ont
dit les aides à east kohler
expressionniste couleurs et figuration
livres scolaires
c'est une très belle façon de se disent
les journalistes se sent pas dire ça
c'est très juste ces voiliers mais en
fait ça va je me suis sorti au début
j'avais un peu peur j'étais en fait
rendu des signaux pas l'étiquette à ça
maintenant je m'en fous parce que je
crois qu on peut voir où ce que tu fais
en ce moment dans ces moments là une
expo des groupes à la gallery d'offres
bouchée des pièces il ya des sculptures
toujours g lara vinci s'est tourné mon
quartier en série de bosshard l'autre
c'est woodsen ils allaient s'afficher
les lithographies rude scène aussi la
capelle documents et à la gravure sur
bois une galette s'attelle à tallinn qui
vient d'ouvrir la bastille il a une
vraie galère avec ceux ouverts fait la
nation la radio revanche et les
portraits l'ami partout au nom wii wheel
a échoué d'artistes génique ciblant peut
se passer ces coups partout on s'est dit
que tu te sentais plus finalement
argentin depuis qu'ils étaient à paris
c'est vrai ça je dis ça peut-être non
c'est enfin je suis retourné parce que
ça fait c'est comme ça que ça allait pas
là la jurée tournée années passent et
finalement je retourne pas marché c'est
bien l'argentine est ce que ce
sous-titré la mission s'il n'a pas sonné
rien comme france ici on comprend très
bien
alors tes influences et buenos aires
quand même se dire c'est tout un
trottoir de buenos aires calculant
l'enfance vingtaine d'années
il a beaucoup de choses que ça c'est pas
ça c'est quand même très leu leu leu
buenos aires un peu populaire mythique
les mauvais garçons les filles de joie
issam el ses frais il ya c'est vrai mais
là il entend je fais comment c'est vrai
qu'il fait
beaucoup de choses on a des sculptures
peintures photographies l'a toujours des
choix différents et la chose que c'est
vrai que ça revient beaucoup alors on
peut dire qu'on voit ces personnages
c'est pas moi qui me propose de ce sont
les autres influences contre connaissez
c'est léger c'est lyon l'union peut être
un peu mais c'est passionnant j'ai connu
après pour que ces conseils les jeunes
me disent alors je vis je regardais pas
refaire du bosquet route a dit que ça
ressemblait à du lion et non j'ai pas
oui je veux pas y avait trop menti ce
moment il ya plein de choses à
dans ma tête je combine tout il a des
chaussures les gens qui travaillent dans
la salle même métier assure lui-même s
univers sont-elles similaires ou les
conjonctions
les gens qui sont peut-être des choses à
exprimer que sont les mêmes donc
peut-être il ya des coïncidences
bon bah je crois que oui je signale mon
nom et borghèse tu l'a découvert là-bas
avant de partir ou après wade sachez que
j'étais très au début j'allais
j'admirais beaucoup je crois que je
comprenais pas tout est bon maintenant
que j'ai tout lu je fais le tour de
chauffe
cette famille j'admire beaucoup
peut-être lui-même influencé beaucoup
mais mes cd point de vue de son univers
plutôt mental d'une façon de
c'est une littéraire de gauche ont
beaucoup trop triste
civique en même temps pour faire un
tableau ça dépend ça peut être être
minutes ça fait trois mois parce que je
fais beaucoup des cahiers sa sécurité
que le parent cahier chez toi ou de
jouer tous les jours tous les jours oui
j'ai tout le temps je vais j'aime
beaucoup les cahiers pas cette formule
liberté c'est plus bombe à g par jour
tout comme 30
donc je dessine j'ai passé une chose à
l'autre et donc les descendants les
cahiers passé empreint de witsel et 5
rayonnages ça pousse à 10h02
et parfois je m'acharne beaucoup sont
même souvent gagné je peux passer des
jours des shows santé ça et d'ailleurs
croire qu'il allait publier un jour chez
ses chances à chacun de ses auditeurs ça
vaut quand même un tableau de toi ça va
d'un petit format 5000 francs par
exemple qui dois-je jusqu'à débris comme
c'est pas très chaude chez le vent libre
et viviane ta peine sûr quand même
beaucoup de frais avant ça coûte cher et
couleurs ne pas les trouver les
matériaux pas tellement mais les fans de
l'atelier
le truc fred
c'est compliqué là je voudrais bien
présent sur la pelouse de tout ça avant
ça sert à quoi la peinture attendait bah
moi et heureusement sinon ce patient je
serai chatte le trailer
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars d'études abonnez vous y mettez un
pouce bleus